So so far we have talked about a journal script of going to a restaurant, or
an abstract script for going to a restaurant. This is like a class. We can
instantiate it. So let's do this same script instantiated with these values with
the greatest variables. So, Salwa is not a customer. Lucas is the waiter.
And so on. And this instantiation is an important aspect of intelligence. Let's
go back to our intelligent agent. It might be that Salwa is really a robot. Now,
how would a robot know what to do in a restaurant? How do we program a robot
in such a way that it would know what actions to take in a particular situation?
Well, suppose that, Salwa the robot, in its memory, had a number of scripts like
this one? And when it entered a restaurant, it invoked the restaurant script,
which told it exactly what kind of actions to take. We could also see how this
script allows Salwa, the robot, to generate expectations, to guess what will
happen even before it happens. There is one more thing worth noting here.
Notice how we are composing scripts of these primitive actions here,
the same primitive actions that occurred in the last lesson.
So, these primitive actions are now providing the fundamental units of
frames that compose together in some causally coherent sequence, make a script.
This brings up another point. Notice how some knowledge structures
are composed out of other knowledge structures. Earlier, we had frames for
these primitive actions, gave them social knowledge structures. Now,
we have scripts which are composed out of these framelike knowledge structures.